so now we have our diagram let's tease
out a little bit the first thing I was
just alluding to was what is it what is
it what is that actually distance right
well let's just pull out our favorite
the absolute value is it right well
let's just wipe the Pythagoras tape
shall we that squared equals what's it
equal our swept so here is here is the
first site a square cos square theta so
i've squared it yeah boss
now what do you look at this you're like
oh hold on a second I care now I could
take out a whole squared sine squared
theta because that's equal to one right
yeah oh that's really cool and then all
you get is our R squared over here oh
wait that just means that the modes at
modern longitude squared is the montrose
is it squared that's not a very useful
way of stabies now this is true okay but
in fact what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
say even though this is true I'm
actually gonna go back to my original
notation right because that will give me
something a little more meaningful and
it means I can convert from one form
this form to the other
okay so really this is x squared and
this is y squared do you agree with that
okay so I'm gonna go back to writing it
in that form x squared plus y squared
cuz I would tend to know what these
values are that is mod Z squared so if I
just what ones in
it is a square root of the squares of
those two dollars okay so so or was the
point of doing that right this is true
if I'm completely in monarch form okay
but it's there's no meaning to it it's a
redundant statement but this this
statement here allows me to convert
right so conversion is useful it will
allow me get from here over there or
vice versa if I need to okay and of
course I'm only taking the positive
square root because the modulus by
definition or I can be zero I suppose if
I run the origin but I don't want it to
be negative okay so I'm excluding that
okay no second we know I can fit this on
here we've got the argument here right
but this too long you will notice if
you're thinking back to the unit circle
right then if fat the argument of an egg
or if I say sorry not on your bagel
yeah I'll give it up a complex number
right if I say okay here's a complex
number tell me what angle do I need to
trace out to get to that complex number
to get in facing in the right direction
okay um that idea is in fact kind of
slip the pasture it sounds like a
function but it's not really because
what's the definition of a function what
is a function a function is a connection
between two values like for instance an
angle and a point by a two-dimensional
representation right such that if you
pull one input you'll get exactly one
output right you know what's coming in
there's only one possible answer okay
but there is not only one possible
answer for the angle that will get me up
to here okay for instance on this
diagram it looks like oh I don't know
maybe it's like a bad isosceles triangle
maybe it's like 45 degrees which in
radians would be 45 degrees that would
come for okay so pilot for would get me
up to here okay so I'll just
in fact write the pilot for is not the
only angle that will get me there right
if I wanted to I could go up by at 4 and
then I could go a further 2 pi around
that would be a whole new angle it would
be 9 PI note for right now you're like
well why would I do that
well you know actually sometimes you'll
see later on sometimes you do want to go
further or sometimes you're defined I
want to have angles that are reflex
angles or whatever like that so 9 point
4 is also the argument of Zen do you see
that it's another direction that I can
face you that will still be get still
get me to that complex number okay so
therefore the argument that as I've
stated it just whatever angle gets me
there it's not a function of it it's a
relation so what we do is we define and
this tends to be written tends to be
written with a capital A we define the
principal argument as in the main one
it tends to be riddled with a capital A
uh what this means is either just want
any argument that will get me there okay
I want a particular argument I want to
be restricted between this is a bit
interesting from negative PI all now go
get my boundary the right way no I don't
want to I want I want to include
positive pi
excuse me okay now where you start
thinking you have these in terms of like
naught 2 to PI naught 2 to pi that's
more to 360 for reasons that will become
clear as we go a bit forward further
we're going to go from negative PI to PI
and it's inclusive of the positive value
so if for instance I picked a point
which is PI radians as a direction where
would that be
think about it because I'm remembering
we're measuring for the positive real
axis so PI radians would be 180 degrees
which be a point here okay
now keep in mind that's what the really
point has an argument of PI radians
right
can you give me another one how about
like say yeah oh yeah or he or he are
everything on the negative real axis has
an argument of pi radians okay for
consistency we say positive PI rather
than negative PI which would get me
there but we want it to be a function we
want to have only one value come out
right which argument do you mean so so
we define it there so watch out that is
a really really subtle difference but I
just put that restriction where we do it
yes you do
yeah now for what it's worth usually
that restriction is not someone you have
to introduce it's one that's stated for
you because like we want a principled
argument which I'm going to do one I
want that one okay so that that's kind
of this restriction is baked into this
language and then we'll usually be
asking losing that question to you
rather than asking you to deployment